Also Leute, ich bin schon da, ich sag bloß nix, ich bin auch gerade erst aufgewacht,
ich hab gedacht, nachdem mein Rechner noch an war, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung warum
ich den vergesse herauszumachen, hab ich einfach auf Stream starten geklickt.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach ein paar YouTube Videos, also ich glaube die nächste Stunde
werden wir nix sonderlich produktives machen, soviel kann ich schonmal sagen, ich guck jetzt
einfach ein paar Videos, die ich in meine Playlist für später angucken gespeichert
habe.
History of Graphics Calculator, was zum Teufel.
Quickmaths.
Hier wollen wir jetzt nicht ernsthaft erzählen, die spielen Gameboy aufm Taschenrechner,
oder?
Na gut, ich mein, warum nicht?
Das erste Grafik-Gelator ist ein Komponentex, das man mit dem Texteinbruch auswählen kann.
Das heißt, man kann es mit dem Texteinbruch auswählen.
Das ist ein Komponentex, das man mit dem Texteinbruch auswählen kann.
Das erstes, was für Tr Colin
hat, das war die TI81.
Versteht man überhaupt was?
Oh, das sieht super bedienerfreundlich aus.
Gut, das hat man damals so gemacht.
Okay, ich stell's vor.
Ist jetzt schon am rechten.
Moment, ist das so ein...
So ein Vorgänger von einem seriellen Kabel, oder was?
So wie bei Gameboy, wo es dieses Link-Kabel gab.
Calculator Multiplayer.
Was, bei euch gab's richtig Ärger, wenn der Lehrer dann spielt auf dem...
Ich wusste noch nicht mal, dass es überhaupt geht.
...Link-Kabel to exchange data with a PC or Mac.
And that was enough to start a whole community of Calculators.
The TI-85 still only offered BASIC as a programming language, running within the confines of the
Calculator's operating system.
But in 1994 it was discovered that by carefully modifying the contents of a backup file and
restoring it to the device, one could get the TI-85 to execute arbitrary code.
Also, die haben...
Das ist ja ein bisschen wie der Wehack.
Das ist ein bisschen wie der Zelda Wehack.
Kann sich da noch einer dran erinnern?
Die haben damals auch...
Auf der Wii, da haben sie das...
Haben sie ein Save-File von Twilight Princess genommen und haben den Namen vom Pferd zu lang
gemacht.
Und dann musstest du rückwärts zu einem NPC laufen und der NPC hat den Namen vom Pferd
ausgesprochen.
Buffer overflow code ausführen.
Bäm.
Das ist ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen ähnlich hier.
By November of that year a piece of software named ZShell was released, which allowed users
to easily launch programs written in ZShell.
to easily launch programs written in assembly.
By November of that year a piece of software named ZShell was released, which allowed users
A variety of programs went on to become available, all written by enthusiasts and shared freely
over the Internet.
Fuck.
Some were practical for math or engineering use, but one particular kind of program seemed
to gather more attention than the rest.
Ich fand, das ist aber klar.
Sobald es geht, dann wird es gemacht.
Ist doch logisch.
Texas Instruments wasn't thrilled about this, and as it developed the replacement for the
TI-81, which would be known as the TI-82...
Easy.
...the company sought to find and fix bugs that could be exploited the same way as in
the TI-85.
It was somewhat successful in its efforts, as the TI-82 was launched in 1993, and it
took until 1997 for enthusiasts to develop an assembly shell.
But at some point TI seemed to realize that allowing assembly programming would actually
be beneficial...
Ja, Sirius Max, können wir da nachgucken.
...official.
...if for no other reason than to make it easier for the company to develop an assembly
shell.
Was sonst?
...to offer its own applications for the platform.
Ja, was sonst?
The TI-83, which launched in 1996, was the first model with official assembly support,
though the feature wasn't initially advertised.
Subsequent models made it progressively easier to write software in assembly, though TI
never made much available in terms of documentation.
Enthusiasts still had to pull a lot together on their own, but the time period of the late
AI was just the time to predict.
Assembler Taschenrechner programmieren ...
What's there?
...still managed to become a bit of a golden era in calculator gaming.
Some were recreations of well-known titles like Tetris, while others were original to
the platform.
Websites like TICalc.org sprung up to provide information, host software downloads and spur
community discussion.
So it's a bit older already.
The programming scene continued to grow and flourish, taking advantage of hardware consumption.
TI calc.org, NIICALC, XAMPP and other software app.
And software developer International.
Next on it's way.
Die Framerate ist jetzt nicht so die allergeilste.
Das sind so 5 FPS oder so.
Inspire.
Das hat bestimmt ein Touch-Interface jetzt.
Alter, das ist ein Taschenrechner.
Das ist ein halbes Smartphone.
Network, Login, das ist ein Taschenrechner.
Warum habe ich auf einem Taschenrechner ein Menü, wo Network und Login drinsteht?
Das ist ein Taschenrechner.
Auf der anderen Seite, wir haben auch unsere Steckdose geflasht letztens.
Und haben sogar ein Web-Interface für eine Steckdose.
Also insofern.
Nur alt.
scripted in a language called Lua. Lua oder Basic? Dann, dann, dann eher, dann eher noch Lua, ja.
... Enthusiasts were stuck. But just like they had over a decade prior with the TI-85,
they set to work, trying to unlock the secrets of the new platform. And sure enough,
by 2010 an exploit was found and jailbreak software called Endless was released. It
included a software development kit. Die Taschenrechner waren doch sehr teuer. Wir gucken mal, wie, wie
ist das? Inspire. Ja, krass. Och, es geht eigentlich. Geht eigentlich. 350 Euro. Ich mein, klar, da kriegt man ein
Einsteiger-Smartphone für. Aber immerhin, geht doch eigentlich. Ja, die jailbreak'n den
Taschenrechner, wenn ich das so richtig sehe. Erste recht, der ohne Kohle. Not just an assembly, but
also also also.
C and C++. But Endless also kicked off a cat and mouse game with Texas Instruments. The company
hadn't simply decided to lock down the Inspire platform. It had an ongoing initiative to keep
it locked down. Subsequent operating system updates brought new features to compel users
to upgrade, but they also fixed the bugs that Endless relied on to work. Okay, also wie auf iOS.
Geh calling. Endless would get updated to work again. Installing the jailbreak is very easy. Just download the version appropriate for the operating system on your calculator. Then copy the files over through USB. Running the program installs the jailbreak in just a couple of seconds. The only caveat is that it's non persistant. So you need to rerun the program every time the Inspire boots up. So far Endless hasn't seen quite the popularity as did.
Er hat Quake-Aufentagerechner.
Es ist auch ein Teil der original-Calculator. Er hat Quake-Aufentagerechner.
Minecraft auf dem Taschenrechner!
Alter, warum?
Naja, weil es geht.
Was sonst?
Oh, Pegelhörer ist da drin.
Den Emulator auf dem Taschenrechner!
Geil, oder?
Naja gut, wenn da eine halbwegs aktuelle ARM-CPU drin ist, warum nicht?
Ah, ein 0,5 FPS.
Obwohl es tatsächlich spielbar ist.
Die perenniale Frage für jedes gebrochene Gerät ist,
kann es Doom spielen?
Normalerweise kann es Doom spielen,
aber mit Endless, die Antwort ist,
naja, ja.
Weil jemand es portiert hat.
Und es funktioniert eigentlich ziemlich gut,
trotz der Kalkulatoren ein bisschen klunzigen Kontrollen.
Aber was vielleicht noch interessanter ist als Doom,
ist Mini-V-Mac,
der, wie sein Name zeigt,
ein Mac-Plus-Rollsystem-System emuliert,
und es ist nicht nur eine Wiederentwicklung
des Desktop-Bereichs,
es ist eine echte OS-Installation.
Der Touchpad-Equipment im Kalkulator
kann die Musik umdrehen, um den Kursor auf dem Bildschirm zu bewegen,
und man kann Programme starten.
Einer davon wird die Meta ziemlich schnell umgesetzt.
Man beachtet mal,
wie schnell sich der Bild
und wie schnell der Bildaufbau ist hier, ne?
Ah ne, so rum.
Neue Hardware-Revisionen
der Inspire CX und CX Caps
haben einen unterschiedlichen Screen-Type,
und nicht alle Applikationen
sind geändert, um damit zu arbeiten.
Endless gibt es einen Impedability-Modus,
um diese Apps zu unterstützen,
aber es funktioniert nicht immer.
Mein eigenes Revision-W-Kalkulator
wird Truxton in Pico-Drive
einfach gut spielen,
mit Sonic 2.
Aber es wird spontan wieder
wenn Quake gefeuert werden,
weil, ja, jemand hat das auch gefeuert.
Das finde ich natürlich besonders geil, ne?
Geil.
Das Ding sieht aus
wie eine Wii-U
von vor 20 Jahren.
Es lite haus.
Ich saute luôn die Wiese raus
und schau das noch mal fertig an.
Oh, das ist ja schön das Ding.
Hab schon Florian als Beitrag
dafür gemacht.
Dann brauche ich halt natürlich
Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Das ist schon geil.
Äh, Flixcode, da verstehe ich auch nicht.
Äh, was
Texas Instruments gegen...
Wartet mal, ich muss kurz was trinken.
Das verstehe ich auch nicht, was Texas Instruments dagegen hat.
Dass man seine Taschenrechner moddet, weil
letztendlich...
Das kann ihnen doch scheißegal sein. Sie haben das Ding verkauft.
Oh.
Ist ja nicht so, dass die irgendwie von
neuen Apps leben würden oder so.
Das ist ein Taschenrechner.
Fixing up a wired fixer.
Ne, ne, wir gucken. Moment.
Ne, wir wollten das Video von Serious Max gucken.
Warte.
The Fall of 76.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, hat nichts mit Overwatch zu tun.
Es geht um Fallout.
150 Euro Taschenrechner
an Schulen.
Naja.
Das muss ja nicht an der Schule sein.
Das kann auch an der Uni sein oder so.
Ähm, also in der Schule,
wir hatten da mal so einen ganz komischen...
Was, Casio...
Irgendwas, warte mal.
Der Richtung sah der aus. Bloß das meine hat
einen gelben Knopf.
Oder ein Sharp? War das ein Sharp vielleicht?
Sharp?
So...
Eher so in...
Richtung...
Egal, aber Taschenrechner, wer braucht sowas heute schon, oder?
Was Fall of 76 ist mega unterhaltsam.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus,
es geht um Fallout.
Hab ich noch nicht geguckt.
Boah. Acht Millionen Aufrufe.
375.000 Likes.
Das Rest waren hier die Bethesda-Fanfics.
Die haben einfach nur die Pay-Accounts, die da oben runtergegeben haben.
Wir mussten uns die Dinge auch selbst kaufen an der Schule damals.
Aber das war nicht so teuer.
Also, das war nicht so der high-end Taschenrechner,
aber hat damals glaube ich auch 50, 50,
haben wahrscheinlich noch Mark gekostet.
Das war damals übelst viel Kohle für mich,
beziehungsweise für meine Mutter.
50 Mark sogar nebenbei.
Weil ich mein, äh...
Alleinerziehend und nicht so viel Kohle
halbtags gearbeitet, äh...
gab's nicht so viel Geld.
Aber jetzt ist ja Easy Money, Easy Life angesagt.
Okay, als Steuerbereiter verstehe ich, dass man Tafelrechner braucht.
Da ist es auch besser, als auf irgendeinem Rechner rumzutippen.
Dann willst du direkt was haben, wo du drauf tippen kannst.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Leuchtet ein.
Ich kann mich daran erinnern, als sie das angekündigt haben,
sind alle Fallout-Fans übelst ausgeflippt.
Und ich finde, damals sah das schon übelst kacke aus.
Das ist was, was ein Marketing-Dude sagt,
wenn er keine Ahnung hat, was er eigentlich sagen soll.
Das sagst du einfach mal irgendwie eine große Zahl.
Viermal die Größe der Map.
Es ist viermal die Größe von Fallout 4.
Und es ist unsere größte noch nicht.
Mein Gott, es war spannend.
November 14th, 2018.
Das Spiel geht live.
Mit einem Tag 1 Patch von 50 Gigabyte.
Fuck's sake.
Ich werde dich morgen sehen.
Aber ein Tag...
Was? Wie viel?
So viel habe ich ja nicht gesehen. Moment.
November 14th, 2018.
Das Spiel geht live.
Mit einem Tag 1 Patch von 50...
Alter.
50!
Okay, 45 Gigabyte.
Das ist so groß wie Titanfall 1 komplett.
Und Titanfall 1 war schon sinnlos groß,
weil sie das Audio nicht komprimiert hatten damals.
Das ist so viel wie Battlefield 4 mit allen DLCs und Maps zusammen.
Am besten war allerdings immer noch dieses eine Tony Hawk Game,
was rausgekommen ist auf der Xbox 360.
Da hatten sie es nämlich so gemacht, dass...
Egal, ich finde es nicht.
Da hatten sie es so gemacht, dass auf der CD oder auf der DVD, die man gekaufen konnte,
war bloß das Tutorial drauf.
Und dass du das Spiel spielen konntest, musst du dich Xbox Live verbinden
und einen Day 1 Patch runterladen, der in Wirklichkeit das ganze Spiel war.
Richtig debated.
Okay, machen wir weiter.
50 Gigabyte.
Fuck's sake.
I'll see you tomorrow.
But once that's downloaded, people start logging into the hellscape that is Fallout 76.
And oh dear lord, they never fix the bugs.
And there are so many of them.
Goodbye world, goodbye necks, goodbye body, goodbye heads, bugs, bugs, bugs everywhere.
Server crashes, game crashes, old bugs imported from Fallout 4.
Use more than one nuke at a time, server's dead.
Text is far too texturous, an all-consuming void.
Error lock 307.
Can't pick up stuff, can't stop asserting dominance with a T-pose.
Framerate problems, screen tear problems, getting too swole, getting underneath a map,
getting attacked by invisible enemies, spawning too many enemies.
Kind of speaks for itself.
Spawning too many god rays.
Also your camp resets after every session and sometimes it goes underwater.
Holitate to randomly play static, but too many holidays mean none of them will play.
Enemy AI is far more A than I.
Animations are broken.
Surprise.
Floating objects and a traveling merchant.
Just to name a few.
Joseph Anderson has a great video that documents just the ones that he found personally.
That video is three hours long.
But it gets worse.
Error CE-348780.
Can corrupt your data and force you to read it.
Scheint ja gut zu laufen.
Console operating system.
A few PC players had their computers brick entirely.
Also when the date rolled over to the 1st of January 2019,
the nukes in the game stopped working altogether.
No one thought it prudent to program in other years in an always online game.
And a few players were straight up logging into other people's accounts.
Was?
Ernsthaft?
This guy had a level 78 character that was randomly replaced with a level 8 parent.
WTF?
Wie unfähig kann man sein?
Ich mein, das ist ja aber wirklich 0815 basic für jede etwas größere Web-Anwendung,
die unterschiedliche User hat.
Also, dass du dich nicht in andere Accounts einloggen kannst.
Es sei denn, du kriegst das Passwort von dem.
Aber anscheinend war es ja so, du hast dich eingeloggt mit deinem Account und auf einmal landest du in einem anderen Account.
The fuck?
Other people's account.
This guy had a level 78 character that was randomly replaced with a level 8 parent.
Bethesda said they couldn't do anything about it.
Hmhm.
And many players are not thrilled with this game.
And they want Bethesda to know that.
And they want everyone else to know that, too.
But Bethesda owns the platform.
Is Fallout 76 fun?
Yes, it is.
Banned for racism. Threadlocked.
What?
Ich geh jetzt mal davon aus, dass es nicht ausgedacht ist.
Es ist echt so passiert.
They had no direct outlet for their rage.
The only solution was to put a torch to everything else.
Reddit.
Twitter.
Bethesda's other games on Steam.
The backlash was a mess.
But surely level heads would prevail.
The reviewers would come out and say that the game isn't so bad.
Oh dear lord, they ain't.
This is so sad.
Despacito, play Country Roads.
Almost heaven.
West Virginia.
Blue Ridge Mountains.
Shenandoah River.
And the YouTube community had this to say.
It's really fucking boring.
I could barely bring myself to play it in order to finish this review.
No one on staff wants to play any more of this video game.
I'm not gonna subject myself to another 20, 30 hours of this fucking mess.
In short, Fallout 76 is morally, technically and creatively bankrupt.
The mods on Bethesda forums were working overtime.
The mods on Reddit almost gave up.
Look, I'm not saying that some people didn't enjoy and have fun with this game.
But what I am saying is that the Metacritic was really funny to read.
So what happened?
Well, it came out that development was hugely rushed.
The deadlines were tight.
Too tough.
But the Metacritic was really funny to read.
So what happened?
Well, it came out that development was hugely rushed.
But the Metacritic was really funny to read.
So what happened?
Well, it came out that development was hugely rushed.
But the Metacritic was really funny to read.
So what happened?
Well, it came out that development was hugely rushed.
But the Metacritic was really funny to read.
So what happened?
Well, it came out that development was hugely rushed.
But the Metacritic was really funny to read.
So what happened?
Well, it came out that development was hugely rushed.
Die Abläufe waren scharf. Zu scharf.
Und das war nicht nur Bethesda's A-Team.
Es ist eigentlich eine relativ unerwartete Division, die in Austin basiert.
Und die Szene des Spiels wurde immer größer.
Wir brauchen distante Wettersysteme.
Hey Todd, ich habe die ganze Nacht geblieben und habe es gerade fertig gemacht.
Wir brauchen 16-mal die Detail.
Bitte, Todd, nicht mehr.
Wir brauchen 4-mal die Größe von Fallout 4.
Das, als ob sie versuchen würden, den alten Bethesda-Kreationen-Engine in eine Multiplayer-Framework zu packen.
Was else könntest du erwarten?
Das ist der Grund, warum ich meinen Kindern Fallout 76 gebe.
Der Verrückte!
Nun, Bethesda konnte die Bugs und die schlechten Reviews und die irren Spieler tolerieren.
Aber was sie nicht tolerierten, waren die Exploiten.
Infinite Inventar, infinite Unwissbarkeit.
Die Framerate war verbunden mit der Spielgeschwindigkeit, also waren die Leute viel schneller, als sie sollten.
Server-Hopping.
Für mehr Items.
Infinite Cash und infinite Duplication.
Sag mal, wenn ich das jetzt...
Ich meine, wir sind jetzt erst 6 Minuten in diesem Video, ja?
Wir sind erst 6 Minuten drin.
Ich habe das Spiel nicht gespielt.
Ich habe nur den Trailer geguckt.
Ich fand das Erste, was sie gezeigt haben, schon blöd.
Aber okay, wir sind 6 Minuten in dem Video.
Also ein Fünftel oder so von dem Video.
Quickmuffs, ein Viertel von dem Video.
Was ich bis jetzt vor dem Spiel gesehen habe, kann das sein, dass das einfach...
Absolut komplett kaputt ist.
Also nicht einfach nur kaputt, sondern undurchdacht, kaputt, verbuggt, ohne jegliches Konzept dahinter.
Ohne durchdachtes Gameplay, ohne irgendwie durchdachtes Spielwert.
Nichts, also einfach so ein komplett dahingeschissenes Produkt irgendwie.
Genau, okay.
Das habe ich jetzt richtig verstanden anscheinend.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt gebonkertost werde.
Moment, was?
Gott, ist das schlecht.
Vor allem, wenn das was ist, wo man nicht will, dass die Leute...
...leute es erreichen, dann sollte man das vielleicht gar nicht ingame einbauen, beziehungsweise überhaupt so gestalten, dass es funktioniert und nicht einfach eine Wand, wo man durchklebt.
Ach du Scheiße.
And someone was given the curse of infinite invincibility.
Naturally, this can really mess with other players' online experience.
So Bethesda was ready with the ban hammer.
And a blindfold to wildly flail around and take down anyone who happened by.
But Bethesda wasn't satisfied with just banning.
No, they're a progressive company, with big ideas.
They wanted to give a road to redemption.
So support sent out this email to players caught cheating.
We would be willing to accept an essay on why the use of third-party cheat software is detrimental to an online game community.
That's right, 500 words on why you're a very naughty boy.
Da sind sie aber nicht die ersten, die das gemacht haben.
Ähm...
In irgendeinem anderen Online...
...Multiplayer-Game...
War das nicht sogar DayZ oder DayZee oder so?
Irgendwo haben sie das doch schon mal gemacht.
Wo du schreiben musstest, warum du ein böser Cheater bist.
Aber ich meine, in dem Fall ist es wirklich ein Witz.
Ich meine, das Game an sich ist es ja nicht so, dass das jetzt irgendwie funktionieren würde.
Und ein paar hätten sich da krass eingehexort.
Wahrscheinlich hat diese Bannwelle auch übelst viele falsche Leute getroffen.
...give you your account back.
But a couple of days later...
...talking from news outlets caused them to reconsider this approach.
One more exploit.
In all the Bethesda games there's a dev room.
Every item in the game is kept here.
Security has to be top-notch, because otherwise...
...someone could just waltz in and take all of the best items of the game...
...and it would be an absolute disaster.
Warum braucht ein Online-Game einen Dev-Room, der auf dem Live-Server drauf ist?
Blummer so.
Ungefragt. Warum? Muss das sein?
Das wissen die Bescheid.
Ich weiß auch nicht so genau, warum das sein muss.
Well, shit.
Of course, Bethesda wasn't equipped to deal with the issue.
People started flooding in, taking the best items in the game...
...then selling those items on a black market site.
At first they tried the usual approach.
Genial.
Obwarten.
Bending people who had some of the best items in the game.
You spent 700 hours just to get the best gun?
Die, cheater!
Next, they put in a system where players would get tagged if they ever entered the room.
And they banned those players.
That wasn't much better, because people would just start using Smurf-Accounts.
Get in quick with a Level-1-Account.
Get all that good shit.
Then get the fuck out.
Then use a duplication glitch to get a ton more of those items.
Then transfer that stuff...
Oh, du konntest auch noch Items dupen?
Gibt es eigentlich irgendwas, was das Spiel richtig gemacht hat?
...to your main account, and you're good to go.
Bethesda then takes out this Level-1 and calls it Mission Account.
Das ist ein Komplett, und du hast einfach das Spiel gewonnen.
So the problem continued.
Bethesda is running out of ideas to solve it.
There's a lot of speculation in the media and among players about how exactly people are getting in.
But no one except for the exploiters knows for sure.
That said, Bethesda needs to act fast before it ruins the economy of the game.
So they wrote another email and sent it out to the Smurfs.
Hello, cheater.
Do you want to tell us how you did it?
And we might...
...unban you, please?
Should we not hear back from you, the account will simply remain suspended.
It's not known whether this approach worked.
But from what I've seen, it's still possible to get into the dev room.
November 22nd, 2018.
Just a week after the release, the game goes on discount.
From 60 to 40 dollars.
Das ist schon bitter.
Das sagt alles.
Von full price zu 35 Dollar.
To 35.
To 30.
You can find it for 15 on Ebay.
And in Germany, they're straight up giving it for free when you buy a Playstation controller.
Also, some stores are just zip-tying it to other products.
Du kannst dich gar nicht mal dagegen wehren.
So, nein, ich will das Game nicht.
Doch, du musst.
Nein, aber ich will das Game nicht.
Dann gibt's auch keine Xbox One.
Some stores are just zip-tying it to other products.
But to Bethesda, it's worth selling the thing at a price close to zero.
Because it brings back the memory of the game.
And it's worth it.
And it brings people into the Atomic Shop.
Which is where the people might be.
Ah, Microsoft Transactions und Ingame Shop hat's auch.
And it includes the poor sales figures.
Let's have a look at those.
The latest figures show 76 or less than a sixth of what Fallout 4 did.
Not good.
There's also been a massive oversupply of hard copies.
Although, what's the point of a hard copy when the thing is just a cardboard disc telling you to redeem an online code?
Ist ja noch schlimmer als das Tony Hawk Game auf der Xbox, wo nur die Demo auf der Disc war.
Da war wenigstens was auf der Disc.
Und obwohl die Säle steigen, sind die Rückzüge hoch.
Im Augenblick, als die Säle ausgelöst wurden, haben die Leute zu Beginn begonnen, Bethesda für eine Rückzahlung zu fragen.
76 ist nicht auf Steam.
Es ist auf Bethesdas eigenen Plattform.
Also haben sie alle Kontrolle.
Tja, das hab ich gehabt.
Wenn die Spieler nur ein paar Stunden die Spiele gespielt haben, dann würden sie generell ihr Geld zurückbekommen.
Aber es kam heraus, dass die Leute manchmal nach einer vollen 24 Stunden Spiele Rückzüge bekommen.
Ganz geniesslich.
Aber dann wurde das zu Foren.
Ich liebe Sidcoming.
Die Post hat 12.500 Rückzüge informiert, dass das fast alle für eine Rückzahlung erlaubt hat, und die Kommentare sagten ihnen genau, wie man das macht.
Bethesda wurde mit Request für eine Rückzahlung überflutet.
Und ihre Antwort?
Schnapp es, Jungs.
Nein, nein, niemand bekommt eine Rückzahlung.
Alle gehen nach Hause.
Die Show ist vorbei.
Robot-Kunden-Serviceman, engagiert euch.
Kunden, die das Spiel gedownloadet haben, sind nicht für eine Rückzahlung erlaubt.
Wir verabschieden uns.
Warum?
Sie haben es gedownloadet.
Ich meine, kannst du das aufrufen, wenn du das Spiel gekauft hast und reingucken willst, um festzustellen, dass das Spiel abfällt?
Wie willst du das machen, ohne zu downloaden?
Man hat jetzt davon abgesehen, dass dein Kram wahrscheinlich sogar automatisch anfängt zu downloaden.
Wir verabschieden uns wegen Ungefährlichkeit.
Alles gut, kein Problem.
Wenn es sonst nichts gibt, können wir dich unterstützen. Bitte antworten.
Ja, ist klar.
Ungefährlichkeit.
Die...
Ein paar Dinge folgten.
Zuerst, die Leute wurden verrückt.
Ein Hardcore-Gamer hat sogar einen GameStop getrascht, um seinen Befehlen zu verfolgen.
Was geht mit dem ab?
Das muss jetzt der nächste sein, ne?
Der GameStop-Dude kann da nichts für.
Zweitens, die Medien...
Und drittens, ein Klassensuchtsatz.
Das ist ja noch viel schlimmer, als ich das überhaupt mitgekriegt habe.
Das ist das Survival-Effekt.
Es hat ja jeder mitgekriegt, dass das Spiel komplett im Arsch ist.
Aber das ist ja noch viel schlimmer, als ich mir das gedacht habe.
Und wisst ihr, wer wahrscheinlich im Endeffekt darunter leiden wird?
Das Team, was das unter diesen beschissenen Vorgaben und dem Spaß entwickeln musste.
Die haben wahrscheinlich die Arschkarte am Ende.
Wahrscheinlich wird das Studio dicht gemacht oder sie werden rausgeschmissen oder sie kriegen keinen Bonus.
Sie haben wahrscheinlich die Arschkarte am Ende.
Die Typen, die es entwickelt haben und wahrscheinlich ihr Bestes sogar noch gegeben haben.
Doch könnte man so sagen.
Die Typen, die es entwickelt haben und wahrscheinlich ihr Bestes sogar noch geben werden.
Und dass Bethesda sich in eine Strategie eingegangen ist, um es überhaupt rauszuholen und dann langsam in einen spielbareren Zustand zu passen.
Die Updates auf diesen Vorgang sind langsam.
Also werde ich euch auf dem zweiten Kanal informieren.
Ad-Zeit.
Schau, da ist ein Meteor, der direkt auf die Erde geht.
Oh mein Gott.
Wir müssen etwas tun.
War jemand genug interessiert, es online zu lesen?
Nicht ich.
Nicht ich auch.
Nein.
Oh nein.
Jetzt denken die Leute, dass ich dumm bin und dass ich eine Völkerin gestorben bin.
Lass dir das nicht passieren.
Nimm ein Curiosity-Spiel.
Es ist eine Streaming-Plattform mit den besten Dokumentaren und Non-Fiction-Filmen.
Partial Nudität.
Vielleicht, wenn du hart genug siehst.
Aber mehr wichtig.
Das Allergrößte.
Dein Wissen.
Es funktioniert für Yoroku, Android, etc.
Es funktioniert für alles, okay?
Wissenschaft, Natur, Geschichte, Technik.
Gesellschaft.
curiosity-stream.com.
Internet-Historian.
Für unbegrenzte Zugang zu den weltweit freien Top-Dokumentaren und Non-Fiction-Serien.
Benutze den Promo-Code Internet-Historian.
Er hört es übelst gehypert.
Er hat es gehypert.
Willst du das sagen, hä?
Ja, sogar ein guter Sellout.
Ja, das hat jeder mitgekriegt, glaube ich.
Mit der, mit der, ach nee.
Ach, das ist es mit der Tasche.
Es gab ja zwei Pre-Order, nennen wir es mal in Anführungsstrichen, Skandale.
Das mit der Tasche und das mit der Cola.
Was ist das?
Das sieht schlechter aus, als wenn du es bei AliExpress bestellst.
Ey, jede 0815 Tasche mit einem Aufdruck von AliExpress wäre besser gewesen.
Das sieht aus wie eine Kühltasche vom Lidl.
Das sieht aus wie eine, oh Mist.
Das sieht wirklich aus wie eine Kühltasche vom Lidl.
Backlash.
Erstmal Face-Roll.
This email in response.
Hello, we are sorry that you aren't happy with the bag.
The bag shown in the media was a prototype and was too expensive to make.
We aren't.
Okay, ey, wenigstens, wenigstens erzählen sie jetzt nix mehr, ja?
Planning on doing anything about it.
Ernsthaft?
Was haben die geschrieben?
Normalerweise labern sie ja da immer noch ein bisschen drumherum.
So nach dem Motto, wir möchten die beste User Experience liefern und bla bla bla.
Bla bla bla, ja, aber, na gut, Leute, ich geh mal davon aus, dass, ähm, was war das mit der Cola, also kommt vielleicht noch, wenn nicht erzähl ich's danach, ähm, ich geh mal davon aus, dass der Support-Mensch einfach keinen Bock mehr auf den Scheiß hat.
Vielleicht war das ein letzter Tag, hat schon gekündigt, hat sich gedacht, ey, mit dem Laden will ich ja nix mehr zu tun haben und hat dann nochmal ein Support-Email rausgehauen.
Genial.
Das ist das ganze E-Mail.
Die Mitarbeiter von Bethesda schlagen nicht mehr ihre Verzweiflung.
Natürlich.
The Internet goes wild.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Wow.
Well, I got so mad, I shaved everything off my face.
Okay, guys, this is a bit of a PR nightmare.
We have to quell the outrage.
What do we do?
Well, we've got this in-game currency.
Let's just give them the minimum amount of that.
Fantastic idea.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was das Schlimme ist bei sowas?
Wisst ihr, was das Schlimme ist bei sowas?
Das ist ja das Erste, was so einem Laden einfällt, so nach dem Motto, lass uns In-Game-Currency verteilen oder lass uns bei einem MMO einen Tag Playtime geben und sowas.
Und wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste daran ist?
Dass 95% der Leute das abfeiern.
Dass 95% der Leute feiern das ab.
Der Hersteller kann den größten Scheiß verzapft haben und sagt dann, ja, wir geben euch einen Gratis.
Wir geben euch einen Gratis-Pad oder irgendwie sowas in einem MMO und die Leute alle, oh mein Gott, ist das geil, ein Gratis-Pad, wir lieben den Hersteller.
Die Leute, das, das, das, das ist das eigentlich Schlimme daran.
Hey, ich mein, guck mal, der Mist hat 6000 Likes.
Moment, wir müssen uns mal die Antworten angucken.
Äh, ähm, ich wette mit euch, die, die, die, die meisten, die feiern das.
Okay, ja, na, jetzt ist zu spät.
Die Antworten anzugucken, jetzt ist ja, ist ja das Ganze drumherum schon, schon passiert.
What are you gonna do with your atoms?
I'm gonna buy 5 18ths of the white paint version of the Power Armor.
Whoa, what about you?
Like wood laminate, like wood laminate, like wood laminate.
Ah, fuck the bag, he's right, fuck the bag.
Like wood laminate.
Like wood laminate, like wood laminate, like wood laminate.
Of course, this was Bethesda's fantasy of what would happen.
What really happened is further outweighing, and even the media started piling on.
Almost heavy on West Virginia.
It even became part of that class action lawsuit from earlier.
Bethesda put out a tweet apologizing for their curt customer service
and gave a different excuse for why they didn't make the bags.
A shortage of material, apparently.
Ja.
That was quickly debunked.
Ist klar.
Ja, die sorgen ja auch dafür, dass noch mehr Leute den Crab kaufen.
Man kriegt teilweise, also ich jetzt nicht mehr, ich mache ja irgendwie keine Videos,
aber zu Zeiten, wo ich nur Videos gemacht habe, du kriegst teilweise random in der Post irgendwelche Dinger geschickt.
Von irgendwelchen Läden, mit denen du dich ganz gut gestellt hast, ja.
Und das ist oftmals kein Crab.
Wie gesagt, beispielsweise die Asus-Mütze, die ist übelst nice, die ziehe ich immer noch gerne an.
Und die tun ja auch irgendwie ganz gut daran, sich da ein bisschen einzuschleimen,
weil letztendlich sorgen die Leute dafür, dass der Crab sich noch mehr verkauft.
Die Xbox-T-Shirts sind auch übelst nice.
Das ist kein Crab, den man da kriegt.
Es ist so, dass es so aussieht, als ob es eine Canvas-Bag im Spiel gibt.
Wenn du den Postmann ausmachst,
welches natürlich auf dem Atom-Shop gefunden werden kann,
für 700 Atome.
Oh, nur kurz.
Ich finde es, wenn ich mir das überlege, das ist ja voll der Witz.
Ey, du kannst dir mit dem, was du als Belohnung kriegst,
dafür, dass deine Tasche eine Lidl-Einkaufstüte ist,
kannst du dir nicht mal den Crab in-Game kaufen.
Also.
Das kenne ich.
Das habe ich mitgekriegt.
Und zwar, was jetzt passiert ist,
was jetzt passiert, du musst jetzt dieses Formular ausfüllen
und dann gibt es eine Seite, wo du gucken konntest,
wer alles sich dafür eingetragen hat.
Public.
Das habe ich mitgekriegt.
Das kommt bestimmt jetzt gleich.
Da gab es eine Seite, da konntest du quasi nachgucken,
wer sich eingetragen hat
und du hast quasi im Klartext Name, Adresse und alles gefunden.
... Personal Details, Adresse, etc.
... And we'll ship out the bag to you in four to six months.
... But it doesn't quite end there.
... Because Bethesda is known for bugs.
And of course their website is a buggy mess too.
Turns out all of the customer support inquiries are unsecure
and open to the public.
In fact, people can open and close and change them at will.
Listed are details of full legal names, phone numbers, home addresses and more.
... Blackfire 21 bestimmt.
Ich meine, sie haben nicht umsonst da jede Menge Klagen schon gehabt am Anfang.
Garantiert.
Und die haben bestimmt noch einige angezeigt.
Und ich hoffe, die kriegen das.
So ein Reingefahren für den Mist.
Ähm, gut ist.
... requested your canvas bag, you've just been doxxed.
Das ist so unfähig, ey.
Das ist so unfähig.
Wie viel Scheiße kann man eigentlich auf einmal bauen?
Und wir sind, das Video geht noch zehn Minuten.
... not knowing how to immediately fix the problem,
Bethesda panics and temporarily shuts down the whole website.
... and that is the tale of the duffel.
How could this have been so difficult?
They made one for New Vegas.
One last piece of merch.
Genau, die Cola.
Nuka-Cola Dark.
Pre-orders available in September.
Shipped out on November 14th.
Eighty dollars plus postage and handling.
Not cheap.
But in return you got a very cool bootle.
Looks good on the shelf.
A great conversation piece with the family over Thanksgiving.
Or at least it would have been.
November 14th can't wait.
It came and went and there was no rum.
Uh, okay.
A week later, on November 21st, an email comes through.
There's a delay.
Things aren't up to the usual fallout standard, they say.
Wonka es?
The usual fallout standard.
Wenn die, wenn die...
Wenn die Colaflasche dem usual fallout standard entsprochen hätte,
würde ich mir die wahrscheinlich nicht in die Wohnung stellen.
Da musst du ja Angst haben, dass die Wohnung abbrennt.
Oder wahrscheinlich klitscht,
wahrscheinlich klitscht dir die Colaflasche in die Wand
und du kriegst sie nicht mehr raus.
But for you soon.
No specific date given.
One week later.
Nothing.
Then on December 5th, another email.
Good news.
We start shipping on December 12th.
It's been nearly three months since you pre-ordered.
But as a show of good faith,
we made this promotional video for you.
And this is where things went from tardy to retardy.
Right there. Did you catch that?
That's just a regular industry bottle
and a plastic shell.
We paid 80 dollars
and waited a quarter of a year
for a plastic shell.
Ey, das könnte ich aus meinem 3D-Drucker ausdrucken.
Das sieht aus wie aus einem 3D-Drucker.
Shell?
Okay, nee, es sieht nicht aus wie aus einem 3D-Drucker.
Es sieht zumindest von dem Abstand nicht aus wie aus einem 3D-Drucker.
Oder zumindest wie aus einem 3D-Drucker
und schön poliert.
Aber sowas kannst du dir aus einem 3D-Drucker schöner ausdrucken.
People were not happy.
Look at that ratio.
Nothing in the marketing said that it was a plastic shell.
Ey, aber,
also das da,
es gibt ein Video, was noch,
also das ist nix.
Das Video mit den schlechtesten Bewertungen
ist immer noch das da.
Gibt's das überhaupt noch?
Gibt's das Video überhaupt noch?
Das Originalvideo gibt's gar nicht.
Glaub ich nicht mehr.
Aber nicht desto trotz,
die sind eh nicht schlecht, die Bewertung.
So fail alles,
so fail.
Da siehst du halt mal, was passiert,
wenn irgendwelche Anzugs-BWL-Köppe
deinen Laden, okay,
jetzt ist wahrscheinlich wieder die Leute,
egal, ähm, das den Laden
übernehmen und die von Games
keine Ahnung haben, von gescheiten Games.
Dann kommt sowas raus.
Habt ihr denn, habt ihr denn
keine Smartphones, Leute?
Moment.
Man kann seine Order noch canceln,
drei Monate danach?
Der Modern Warfare Trailer,
der Modern Warfare Trailer hat doch ganz gute,
ganz gute Bewertung, oder?
Der hat saumäßig gute Bewertung.
Infinity War hatte scheiß Bewertung,
aber ich glaube nicht so schlecht.
War es ein bisschen lauter?
Das ist ein bisschen kräftiger.
Ich habe das schon in einem Walking-Log
gelesen in einer Kiste,
und ich habe es rausgeschmissen.
Oh, wie sie schmerzt.
Gut.
Da ist schlecht.
Das war ein bisschen schrecklich.
Ach ja.
Das schläscht.
Moment Leute, wir gucken jetzt mal was.
AliExpress, Nuka-Cola-Bottle.
Es gibt keine Nuka-Cola-Bottle an AliExpress, da bin ich jetzt aber enttäuscht.
Also da bin ich von den Chinesen echt enttäuscht.
Aber es gibt genug andere.
Ja, was sonst?
Ja, gerade recht.
Du hast immer die Leute, das finde ich eh bei vielen Sachen komplett lächerlich, ne?
Du hast die Leute, die übelst, so die richtig Hardcore-Fanboys hast du immer.
Die quasi jeden Strohhalm nehmen, um irgendeine Firma zu feiern.
So was weiß ich, PSN ist kaputt, drei Tage am Stück und Sony schreibt dann irgendwie,
ja, aber wir behauen irgendwie so 0 nach 15 Marketing-Tweet raus nach dem Motto,
ja, wir sind immer, unser Ziel ist es immer die bestmöglichste Online-Erfahrung zu bieten.
Hast du sofort die Fanboys am Start, so nach dem Motto, ja, was erwartet ihr auch von einem kostenlosen Service?
Na ja, gut, der Service ist dabei, wird beworben, ich erwarte, dass der funktioniert.
Also mittlerweile ist PSN nicht mehr kostenlos, ja, mittlerweile kostet das was.
Aber du hast immer so irgendwelche Fanboys am Start und es ist das Dümmste, was du machen kannst,
weil die Firma, also das Unternehmen an sich, die scheißt ja komplett auf diese Leute.
Es ist ja nicht mal, als interessiert das dir jemand.
Das ist so richtig, das ist richtig dumm, so dieses ultra-Gefanboye von irgendwelchen Marken,
von irgendwelchen Unternehmen, vor allem so grundlos-Gefanboye.
Ja.
Und sie wurden auch in ein paar anderen Tomfuckern engagiert.
Vordem das Produkt noch einmal vorhanden war,
haben sie ihre eigenen Produktreviews mit ein paar 5-Star-Szenen veröffentlicht.
Ja, was sonst?
Das hat einige Augenbrauen erhöht und Leute auf Reddit haben sie sogar ausgesprochen,
also haben sie sie geladen.
Du kannst all diese Aktivität auf der Weg-Hin-Maschine sehen.
Nun, wenn sie glücklich sind, Leute in dieser Weise zu verurteilen,
scheint es siebenswürdig, ihnen den Vorteil des Wunschens über das Glas zu geben.
Es ist auch wert, schnell über die Bethesda-Merch-Store zu sprechen.
Einige dieser Items sind ziemlich neugierig.
Das ist cool.
Gute Idee.
Ich habe das.
Fallout 76-Pant.
Singular.
Aber warum ist er so verrückt?
Die Fotografie ist alles nur ein bisschen...
Oh, das ist ein bisschen unglückliches Foto.
Diese gordige Jacket wurde auf Social Media unverzweifelt verurteilt.
Aber macht der 76 in 276...
Alter!
Ist das denn der Ernst?
Ist das für Leute, die Geld scheißen?
Für so eine Plastik?
Plastik... Plastik-Jäckchen?
276 Dollar?
...Dollar, die es wirklich immer mehr immersiv machen.
Und warum haben sie es einfach auf den Boden geschnitten?
Und es kommt in diesem krümmelten Todler-Bodybag.
Du sprichst von Hunderten von Tausenden von Dollar in Merch und du hast keinen Iron?
Warum trägt sie die Größe XXL? Sie ist klar nicht glücklich darüber.
Aber wer hat sich das angeschaut und gesagt, gut gemacht?
Print.
Nun, das ist überraschend.
Oh.
Und was zur Hölle?
Sie haben die Bottle richtig gemacht.
Oh.
Ja, aber die kannst du dir für 30 Euro kaufen.
Ist das so hart?
Gehen wir zurück zum Spiel.
Dezember 2018.
Es sind zwei neue Patches veröffentlicht, die sehr viel Verwirrung verursachen.
Das Gute.
Für PC haben sie ein paar Qualitäts- und Lebensbedingungen eingeführt.
Insbesondere Push-to-Talk.
Gun.
Ups.
Äh, heißt das...
Habe ich das jetzt richtig, richtig gesehen?
Das Game hatte...
Das multiplayer-Game mit Voice Chat hatte keine Push-to-Talk-Option.
...the game.
Dezember 2018.
Es sind zwei neue Patches eingeführt, die sehr viel Verwirrung verursachen.
Und das Gute.
Für den PC haben sie ein paar Qualitäts- und Lebensbedingungen eingeführt.
Was auch Push-to-Talk involves.
Future.
Doch es gibt auch Field-of-View-Drehschleifen.
Hurray.
Das erhöhte Stash-Kapazität von 400 Pfund zu 600 Pfund.
Und außerdem hat das Spiel einen viel besseren Mehrwert.
Und ein kleiner Buff für automatische Waffen.
Hooray!
Sie haben den Carry-Weight von Bobby-Pins reduziert,
sodass es nicht mehr 10-20% der Inventarier der Menschen nahm.
Ich habe eine Box von Bobby-Pins die letzte Woche, die sagte,
dass sie Weih-Diese sagten.
Es gab auch Upgrades zum Camp, die für einfache Konstruktionen ermöglicht haben.
Und ein paar Bug-Fixer.
Hooray!
Der Böse.
Ein ganz großer Bunch unerlässlicher Stealth-Nerfs.
Das ist ja fast wie bei Blizzard.
Time-Sync.
Oh, scheiße.
Ich habe meinen Tee umgekippt.
Ich muss mal kurz Zauber machen.
Glück ist nix auf dem Rechner gelaufen oder so.
Raspberry lag auch nicht drin.
Das ist doch auch schon mal gut.
Es lag ein Brief von Unity Media drin.
Das ist jetzt wirklich wild.
Der ist jetzt komplett durchweicht und im Arsch.
Aber okay.
Ich glaube, es geht wieder.
Gut.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie ich das geschafft habe, ehrlich gesagt.
Die Tasse steht relativ weit weg.
Keine Ahnung, wie ich das geschafft habe, umzuschmeißen.
Ach, je.
Okay.
Es war kurz, es wäre kurz vor MonkaSmoke, war das.
Wenn ein paar Zentimeter nach rechts wäre es zumindest auf den Streaming-Rechner gelaufen.
So, zum Glück habe ich noch ein bisschen Tee da.
Gleich mal retryen.
Aber ich habe jetzt eine Klopapierrolle hier.
Keine Ahnung, was passiert.
So, weiter.
Moment.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo wir gewesen sind.
Ach, dass sie genervt haben.
Weil alle wussten, warum Bethesda das gemacht hat.
Um Menschen zu ermutigen, den Atom-Shop zu nutzen.
Und lass uns kurz darüber sprechen.
Ja, klar.
Time-Sync.
Erhöhen, dass die Leute In-Game-Zeug kaufen.
Weil spätestens jetzt ist denen ja klar, das Game wird von sich keine großartige Kohle mehr abwerfen.
Jetzt muss man versuchen, die paar verbliebenen Leute noch irgendwie so, wie es geht, in den In-Game-Shop oder möglichst viel im In-Game-Shop aus den Leuten rauszudrücken.
Und das Beste ist, dass die Leute nicht mehr in den In-Game-Shop gehen.
richtig gutes video
ist das game mittlerweile halbwegs spielbar ich habe das game weder gekauft noch gespielt in letzter zeit aber ich tippe mal auf nein
Richtig gutes video
also ich meine er hat ja schon acht millionen aufrufe das ist schon mal sehr nice
aber ihr könnt ja mal vorbeigehen und auch noch mal liken oder commenten wir wollen uns jetzt hier nicht den content
Rippen
Youtube
was hat denn der sonst noch so ich kenne den überhaupt nicht
was hat denn der sonst noch so
Mr. Krabbing auf Denk Memes
jeder hat noch mehr zeug
also
das war ein richtig gutes video
richtig nice
like comment subscribe
patreon
donation alles
Okay
was hat man als nächstes video ich muss mal
gucken
leute ich gehe mal kurz aufs klo
wenn ihr irgendwas habt was wir noch gucken gucken müssen unbedingt schickt es mal ansonsten nehme ich aus meiner playlist das nächste
und dann sind wir glaube ich auch demnächst mal wach
was so jetzt bitte ein bisschen clickbait prank und challenges
oh ja unbedingt
reaction wir reakten einfach
wir gucken jetzt noch einen
noch mal ein ur alt video
elf jahre es wird ja immer älter
ich habe auch übelst lustig
assassins creed
ja leute
480p
Die sind ja ich weiß gar nicht ob die den neuen assassins creed immer noch so durch die menge laufen muss alles antatschen
alle der typ der wird den hätten sie 100 pro heute schon instant verhaftet
Da würde ich mich auch verpissen
Alter alles gut alles gut
Hätten sie heute schon instants instants instants geschnappt und getasert die waren echt ihrer zeit voraus
wenn sie heute wenn die heute videos machen das wird voll durch die decke gehen
Also ich habe ich habe keine meine playlist guckt ich hätte jetzt noch 22 22 videos drin die man gucken könnte und zwar einmal hätte ich was
in 10 top top 10 insane shits happen at gaming tournaments
Ok anscheinend habe ich mir gedacht das klingt interessant oder top 10 sachen you didn't know about javascript
Was wollen wir was wollen wir gucken geht beides irgendwie zehn minuten
Also es ist übrigens gar nicht top 10 javascript es ist
You didn't think you didn't know
was primitive technology hat was neues
primitive technology das
oh mein headset
mein headset
Was jetzt los
Hatte das auch gerade das ist übelst rumgespackt
ich habe das übelst
gerausche im headset
als das video aufgemacht habe
Ach das sind die videos ja das kenne ich der baut jetzt zehn minuten lang der baut jetzt zehn minuten lang irgendwas
baut er denn diesmal
ein ofen
der hat schon verdammt viele öfen gebaut
also gefühlt jedes dritte video baut
an den ofen das gucke ich auch immer bin ich sehr finde ich sehr entspannend diese sorte von videos
dass das ja
Bad shit crazy things happen at gaming tournaments
Gaming tournaments can be
Experiences, but since we can't all go to them. We can talk about what happens at them erstmal 4k
I'm falcon in today on game ranks 10 bad shit crazy things that hat warum muss das ding eigentlich bad shit crazy heißen
klickt der leute drauf oder wie
wahrscheinlich
number 10 in a counter-strike tournament in russia of course in russia a team promoter
Tried to mess up another team by bringing a ton of strippers
Into the game room while the tournament was happening who were instructed to do everything they could to distract the players
Now this is why we call people pro gamers. This meant nothing to the players. They were not distracted one
2009 der gut
2009 okay, dass das
Das war noch andere zeit
Was hast du eigentlich für eine leitung naja nachdem ich jetzt meinen vdsl bei der telekom gekündigt habe also das läuft jetzt noch, eine woche
Habe ich aktuell nur die
5 mbit ab und 100 mbit down von unity media aber sobald das umgeschaltet wurde
werde ich upgraden auf
40 ab 400 down von unity media
professionalism in all seriousness
Das ist beeindruckend. Du kannst mich während ich ein Spiel spiele, durch kleine Geräusche zu machen.
Hör auf, ich versuche dieses Spiel zu spielen!
Geh!
Wenn ich mein Headset auf habe, lenkt mich nichts ab.
Der professionelle koreanische StarCraft-Spieler...
Das kennen wir schon, das haben wir schon geguckt im Stream.
Das kennen wir schon, das ist der Dude, der mit seinem Fuß spielt.
...dass er, um seinen Gegner zu schießen, und um es all die mehr zu überraschen,
seinen Fuß zu benutzen, um das Spiel zu spielen.
Ich meine nicht nur, dass er seinen rechten Hand und seinen linken Fuß benutzt,
das ist aber immer noch geil, ey.
Das haben wir aber schon mal geguckt, vor einem Jahr oder so.
In einem Spiel zwischen Christopher González und Naoto Sako
hat ein offensichtlicher Fan von González das Spiel überrascht...
Okay, Fighting-Games kenne ich mich null aus.
...und hat ihm ein paar Tipps gegeben, um zu gewinnen.
Kennt man die Dudes?
Zumindest offensichtlich. Ich kann dir nicht sagen, was er tatsächlich gesagt hat.
Aber hey, erinnerst du dich, wie ich in der ersten Sache gesagt habe,
dass sogar das kleinste Geräusch mich manchmal bei Videospielen verletzt?
Ja, das war ein Spektakulär-Event, in dem er gegen jemanden war, der im Spiel unmöglich gut ist.
Das Spiel war fertig. Er wurde einfach verabschiedet.
Also haben sie den Fan aus dem Stadion rausgekippt und versucht, die Spieler zu resetten,
wo sie vorher waren.
Ich meine, dass die Bühne überhaupt so weit unten ist, dass du mal draufjumpen kannst,
ist auch schon mal merkwürdig.
Das war ein extrem dicker Move auf der Seite von wem auch immer das war.
Nr. 7, ein professioneller CSGO-Spieler, wurde in der Mitte eines Turnieres Wack-Banned.
Ja, da gab's...
Das ist aber nicht nur einer, da gab's ein paar.
Da gab's ein paar Wack-Bands von, äh, in Turnieren.
Ein Team, das Team-Property genannt wurde,
wurde in einem Spiel zwischen...
ihrem Team und HellRaisers 9...
Das ist halt echt fehl.
... für Leute, die CSGO oder irgendwelche Multiplayer-Sachen auf Steam nicht spielen.
Wack?
Um Wack-Banned zu sein, bedeutet das, dass das Valve-Anti-Cheat-System,
das V.A.C., dich vom Spiel planen hat.
Das bedeutet, Emilio von Team-Property,
hat mit Cheating-Software in einem Multiplayer-Spiel
in einem vollblutigen, echten Turnier gearbeitet.
Für Mone.
Das ist Geld für Leute, die nicht Idioten sprechen.
Ja, er wurde von allen zukünftigen Turnieren gebannt
und sein Team wurde von diesem Turnier nicht qualifiziert.
Schau, ich habe gesagt, dass Cheating in Singleplayer-Spielern
den Eindruck der Person hat,
aber Cheating in Multiplayer-Spielen ist schmutzig.
Vor allem, wenn es, weißt du,
ein echtes Turnier gibt,
das vielleicht für Geld ist.
Das sind die Leidenschaften der Leute,
die du versuchst, zu cheaten.
Nummer 6.
In einem japanischen Turnier
eines Spiels namens World of Tanks
hatten sie einen Pornstar,
der im Grunde eine Art Host des Events war,
aber auch...
Und das ist das verrückte, verrückte Teil.
Wenn Leute verloren,
würde sie ihre Panties entfernen
und ihr Autogramm...
Also, die Japaner!
Die Japaner!
... und sie an den Verlierer geben.
Nun, bevor du fragst, wieso wir darüber sprechen,
erinnere dich daran, was der Titel dieses Videos ist.
Und ja, das ist einfach so offensichtlich ausländisch.
Und es scheint nicht so ausgeschlossen zu sein.
Nummer 5 in einem StarCraft Turnier
im Jahr 2012
3.000 Menschen...
Vielleicht sollte man...
Vielleicht ist es ja auch eine Anregung für manche,
dass sie sagen, sie streben eine Pro-Karriere
in World of Tanks an.
3.000 Menschen...
... schreien...
Wir wollen Land!
Wir...
Was?
Moment.
Wir...
Im Jahr 2012
3.000 Menschen...
... schreien...
Wir wollen Land!
Nun, Land bedeutet...
... lokales Spiel.
Aber das ist nicht nur für keinen Grund passiert.
Der Multiplayer im Spiel wird durch battle.net gefunnelt
und erlaubt kein lokales Spiel.
Und während des Turnieres,
gerade als ein Spiel zu Ende war,
wurde die Verbindung zu battle.net verloren.
Stimmt.
Die hatten damals ja noch kein Replay.
Die hatten in StarCraft...
Da muss ich das mal überlegen, ne?
Die hatten ja noch keine Replay-Geschichte in StarCraft damals.
In StarCraft 2.
Das kam ja, glaube ich, erst mit dem zweiten Add-on oder so, ne?
Vielleicht ist da jemand auf einem besseren, laufenderen Stand als ich,
was StarCraft angeht.
Aber mittlerweile haben sie das.
Sie hatten das Problem, dass du Matches,
und das ist eigentlich total beknackt,
Online-Turnier-Matches,
wo, wenn die Verbindung zwischendrin abgebrochen ist,
konntest du die nicht an der Stelle weitermachen,
wo du aufgehört hast,
sondern musstest komplett replayen.
Das ist ein Pool-Match in einem vollblutigen Turnier.
Nun, das ist jemand, der tatsächlich,
ohne ein verdammtes Ding zu sehen,
weiß, wo sein Charakter auf dem Screen war,
welche Richtung sie sich befinden,
und genau, was man tun muss,
um einen gekennzeichneten Gegner zu gewinnen.
Es ist nur so, dass ein timing-basiertes Spiel,
das ich ehrlich gesagt nie spielen konnte, ohne es zu schauen,
es ist eine vollblutige Visual Experience für mich,
war im Grunde genommen von jemandem gewonnen,
ohne irgendeine Sicht.
Wie, an keinem Punkt konnten sie es mit Sicht übertragen,
und versucht, es zu transferieren.
Das ist effig!
Kann man nicht vorstellen, wie das funktionieren soll.
Weil ich meine, bei Fighting Games kommt es ja ganz extrem drauf an,
dass du erstens das schnell siehst, verarbeitest,
und eine schnelle Reaktion hast.
Ein Mann, namens Revan,
wurde verurteilt, dass er nicht während des Turnieres rausgekommen wäre.
Das kann ich mich daran erinnern.
Nun, das ist eines der besten Dinge, die je passiert sind.
Weil, statt rauszugehen,
was übrigens das Tätigkeitsmuster ist,
ist es der Tätigkeitsmuster,
dass du die Gegner-Lokationen ausrufst,
sobald du das Terrain beobachtest,
um sicherzustellen, dass jeder weiß,
wo sie ihre Aufmerksamkeit fokussieren sollten.
Er hat bemerkt, dass nichts passiert ist,
und das ist der Grund, weshalb er sich nicht ausruft.
Er wurde weiter gefragt,
um sich wieder auszurufen.
Also, anstatt einfach zu sagen,
okay, ich habe gesagt, was passiert ist,
hat er angefangen, das Gefühl auszurufen,
dass es nichts da war.
Es gibt niemanden in der Box,
es gibt niemanden in der Box,
es gibt niemanden hier,
das war der Top- vomit.
was passiert jetzt?
Da kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Ich würde...
70 Sekunden ungefähr operates IE.
Bhwa was überhaupt?
Was Ghost?
Beide auch….
Ich kan,t nur sagen,
dass man sich einfach mal
Schaut auf YouTube-Videos.
Das war's für heute.
Also, Bad Shits, Sachen in der Gaming-Competition fällt mir jetzt nichts ein.
Sachen, die wirklich Shit waren, fällt mir das Battlefield 1-Event ein.
Aber das ist ja keine Gaming-Competition.
Ich fand den mit dem Fuß am besten.
Ja, ich auch.
Der Typ, der mit dem Fuß spielt, ist super.
Silent Pain hat noch was geschickt.
The worst CSGO-Tournament ever.
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt noch.
Das geht nur neun Minuten.
Das gucken wir noch.
Und dann muss ich jetzt noch...
Und dann muss ich mal aufs Klo.
Wisst ihr, was mir gerade auffällt, Leute?
Wir machen Reaction-Videos.
Wir machen einen Reaction-Stream gerade zu Reaction-Videos, die reacten.
Das ist, das ist, äh, super-Meta, ey.
Ach, mir ist doch noch was eingefallen, was, was richtig Mist war, Competitive.
Es gab mal von MSI...
Oh nein, ich, ich, ich...
Ich...
Flamie, nicht immer auf MSI rum, weil sie mich gebannt haben, sondern in dem Fall haben sie es wirklich verkackt.
Ähm, sie haben mal ein Overwatch-Turnier gemacht, was nie stattgefunden hat.
Was acht Stunden, acht Stunden ne Warteschleife hatte.
Es geht gleich los.
Das war das schlimmste Tournament je.
Es war verrückt.
Gaming Paradise war das Gehirn von Sasa Bullock, dem CEO eines Tournament-Organisers,
der The Gaming Resorts genannt wurde, was, komisch gesagt, nicht ein echter Resort war.
Das Event war geplant, Dota- und CSGO-Tournaments zu halten, mit einem 50.000-Dollar-Preis-Pool für jeden in Porto-Roslovinia,
eine kleine Stadt auf der adriatischen Küste des Landes.
Bullock war ein Software-Ingenieur, der keine Event-Produktion-Erfahrung hatte,
also hat er sich zu Petar Marković und seiner Tournament-Organisers-Familie Gaming.rs umgekehrt, um sein Tournament...
Klingt, klingt schon wahnsinnig vertrauenserweckend, Gaming.rs.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist denn RS überhaupt für ein Top-Level-Domain?
Serbien.
Okay, ich glaube, ich war noch nie im Leben auf der Domain-RS.
Okay.
Die Teams flogen in Slowenien für den CSGO-Tournament.
Der Gaming-Resort war verantwortlich für die Busse von dem Flughafen bis zum Publikum.
Aber die Busse waren zu spät, und die Spieler kamen nicht auf das Publikum, bis um 3 Uhr morgens.
Wir flogen nach Wien in etwa eineinhalb Stunden.
Wir warten noch eineinhalb Stunden, bis die Organisatoren und alle Teams uns auf den Bus bringen und wir in Slowenien fahren.
Im Endeffekt...
Klingt ja nach ganz toller Organisation.
... in Slowenien.
Die nächsten Tage waren die Spiele gehalten...
Ach, ich glaube, das kenne ich.
Ist das das Hotel, wo irgendwie einer am Ende dann eine Lebensmittelvergiftung von den Spielern hatte?
Ist das das?
Da war doch irgendwas...
... wo die Spieler dann eine Lebensmittelvergiftung hatten, ist das das?
... aber alles wurde belastet, wegen einer schweren Sturm, die durch die Stadt flog.
Ähm...
Eine Sturm?
Ich weiß nicht, warum sie mir gesagt haben, dass eine Sturm-Vergiftung...
... eine Sturm-Vergiftung war.
Und jetzt ist es so, dass es jetzt Regen gibt...
... und es ist so...
... dunkel...
... und es ist nicht sehr schön.
Es ist so, als ob wir...
... nicht weit vom Meer gekommen sind, ja?
Und dann ist es so, dass es so ist.
Nun, sie sagten, dass es heute keine Spiele geben wird.
Aber morgen werden wir...
Das ist ja schon mal... allein das ist ja schon mal Fail...
Was sollen sie denn spielen von 8 Uhr morgens bis 4 Uhr 20 Uhr nachts, oder wie?
... was ist denn das?
Es war ein echter Akt des GOTTES.
Ein Zeichen aus dem Himmel, dass dieses Turnier verurteilt wurde.
Und trotzdem...
... wird das echte Spiel nur in ein paar Monaten beginnen.
Im letzten August...
... ging das Gaming-RS ins Publikum, um alles aufzusetzen.
Es gab...
... nur ein Problem.
Es gab keine PCs.
Laut Markovic...
... waren die Gaming-Resorten verantwortlich...
... für das Abnehmen von Computern aus einem Gaming-Café...
... in Brüssel, zwölf Stunden weg.
Aber einer ihrer Fahrer...
... ging komplett MIA.
Er wurde nur mit einem Fahrzeug verletzt...
Der hat...
... der hat die PCs geklaut.
Was war wichtiger?
Die PCs...
... oder die Monitore?
Sie haben die Monitore geklaut.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, warum auch nicht.
Was?
Was tatsächlich passiert ist...
... die Computern kamen nie.
Also...
... haben sie...
... ihre Gedanken verändert.
Sie haben...
... einige andere...
... PCs...
... die nicht wirklich für...
... das Gaming...
... waren.
Diese PCs hatten keine Grafikkarten...
... und...
... diese kamen etwas zu spät...
... also...
... haben sie dann versucht...
... Grafikkarten zu bekommen...
... damit wir das Turnier machen können.
Oh Gott.
... ohne die PCs aus Brussels...
... waren die einzigen...
... die die mehr Computer hatten...
... 20 alte Arbeitstätten...
... mit...
... einer anderen Ziffern...
... und Grafikkarten.
Aber nicht zu worry...
... sie haben die Computer...
... verarbeitet...
... dank...
... schädlicher Bitcoin-Miner...
... aus Slowenien...
Das Problem war...
... dass die Spielstücke ...
... wieder gut gedeckt waren...
Alles...
... in weniger als einer Woche...
... bevor das Turnier...
Na atleast haben sie...
... ein schönes Stage...
... das CSGO Turnier...
... wurde im September 6...
... aber...
... natürlich...
... war es verlagert.
Wenn die Games tatsächlich begannen...
Ja, und was machst du mit den Leuten?
Ich meine, da haben sich Leute Tickets für gekauft, also eventuell.
Die Teams sind angereist für die Games, wie sieht's mit Preisgeld und allem aus, hallo?
Du kannst das nicht ab gleichem Tag canceln.
Dünnschiss.
Nein, Dünnschiss ist das Schlimmste, was ich mir vorstellen kann, während so einem
Event.
Dünnschiss.
Means I'm not at the police.
Okay, nein das ist了schlimmer als Dünnschiss.
...who came and told me that he can't get his passport from the reception of the whole
marina.
where this venue is and the hotel and everything.
Wir haben nicht genug bezahlt, um uns die persönlichen Ideen zu geben und um zurück in die Räume zu kommen.
Das war ein riesiges Problem.
Die Spiele-Resorten haben nicht wirklich für das Hotel oder die Marina bezahlt, die das Tournament hostet.
Und während sie versuchen, herauszufinden, was das Problem war, haben die Polizei einfach...
Profis am Werk.
Jetzt waren die Spieler enttäuscht.
Keine Weile aus Slowenien, in einem Tournament mit keinem Essen, keinem Computer und immer mehr, keinem Hoffnung.
Drei der Teams waren supposed to be playing in the ESL-ESCA-Invitational Tournament in Dubai just a few days later.
But of course everyone was stuck.
Not just the teams trying to escape to a better tournament.
Other tournaments have messed up in the past, but nothing has ever been this bad.
A couple of missing computers and technical delays is nothing compared to being stranded in a foreign country without your passport.
To make matters worse, representatives of the venue, also pissed off that they weren't paid, decided to lock all the production staff out.
Gamers.rs tried to save the event, negotiating with police to get passports back and unlock the venue, but there was more bad news.
Remember Sasa Bullock, the gaming resort CEO?
He showed up and told all the teams that they weren't going to be paid the prize money they were owed.
In fact, the tournament was cancelled unless all the teams agreed to being paid up to 90 days after the tournament ended.
Is' klar. Also spätestens jetzt hätte ich echt geguckt, wobei, sie haben ja schon versucht, sich aus dem Staub zu machen.
And they all agreed.
So, we called an urgent meeting with all the players and...
Es blieb ihnen ja auch nichts anderes übrig, was sollten sie dann machen?
...the situation. That's why we got the whole delay thing today.
And we also invited the CEO of the gaming resorts.
So he talked with them and the final decision is to continue the games.
The players will sign a contract with exclusively the gaming resorts for that matter.
And, after a few matches were cut short due to time constraints,
Kinguin ended up winning the tournament and walked away with a 90-day IOU for $30,000.
Despite the promises for Bullock...
Haben sie das Geld jemals gekriegt?
...like, no prize money was ever actually paid out.
Haha, das wundert mich nicht. Das wundert mich.
The gaming resorts filed for bankruptcy and Bullock disappeared.
I remember he said something about it.
He said, like, this is by far the best tournament ever.
And then he ended everything in, like, Hail Satan or something.
He said something like that.
It was so weird.
And he was, like, signing papers left and right about everyone is getting money.
Ähm...
Ja gut, wenn er dann nach E-Plan...
...Hail Satan, sowas.
Wenn er das wirklich gesagt hat, wäre das echt eines der merkwürdigsten Dinger, die er wahrscheinlich je gehört hat, ey.
Ich mein, wenn du danach, ähm...
...Pleite gehst, dann kannst du sonst wie viele Schecks unterschreiben.
...but much more money and bla bla bla and then everyone.
Like, he just disappeared.
He did, however, give the Daily Dot one more quote for everyone to remember him by.
It was my first event, he said, and I still did much better than anybody around.
Ja, das war wahrscheinlich auch nicht schwierig.
Bullock's experience turned his Dreamhack-esque fantasy into a laughing stock.
Gaming.rs was left to clean up the mess.
They helped teams get their players to Dubai for the Invitational.
They helped players get their passports back.
They pretty much cleaned up everything they possibly could have.
Their CEO even did a Reddit AMA where he answered any question that he could.
Gaming Paradise is, without question, the worst LAN ever.
It had everything.
Busted computers, seized passports, a literal act of God.
You couldn't write a more perfect disaster.
E-Sports production has come a long way in the last couple of years.
So, remember.
Next time you're complaining in Twitch-Chat about how bad a tournament seems to you,
it could have been a lot worse.
It could have been Gaming Paradise.
Thanks for watching.
If you want more great content just like this...
Let's go back to 16!
I'm im
...
..
....
...
MSI hat mich mal irgendwann auf Twitter gebannt, weil ich wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich mich über ihre RGB-Beleuchtung lustig gemacht habe.
Vermute ich mal, ich weiß es bis heute nicht, was genau, ähm, was jetzt genau das Problem war.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Aber sie war in der Meinung, das war so, so schlimm und, äh, offensive, dass ich mich über ihre RGB-Beleuchtung lustig gemacht habe, dass man mich bannen muss.
Vielleicht hosten wir noch irgendjemand, zeig ich mal her.
Twitch.
Hat eigentlich gestern noch jemand, den, äh, den ich gehostet habe, den mit der Grafikkarte weitergeguckt?
Hat er es noch geschafft, das Ding umzubauen?
Okay, es gibt keine deutschen Science-Technology-Streams so richtig.
Wirtschaft für Schüler, igitt, Wirtschaft.
Der Nico, der den hostet, wenn nicht, der hat schon mehr, mehr Sachen.
Aber den scheinen sie noch zu geben, äh.
Ähm, okay, wen haben wir denn hier noch auf Deutsch?
Wie hieß der, den ich, du meinst, den ich gehostet habe?
Äh, äh.
Äh, keine Ahnung, ähm.
Irgendwas mit Monster, glaube ich.
Irgendwas mit Monster.
Habe ich das richtig? Wir sind auf der ersten Seite mit dem Stream hier.
Na gut, um die Uhrzeit ist kein Match on, so richtig, ne?
Okay, keine Ahnung, ähm.
Hast du nicht damals sogar was zusammen mit Inscrub gemacht?
Ja, mit, mit dem Nico und dem, dem Benni war das damals.
Da war, da war er aber noch nicht Lifestyle, äh, Fitness, äh, Channel.
Aussegeln Japan.
Nee, ich hoste jetzt keinen, ich gehe jetzt off und, ähm, in zwei, drei Stunden bin ich wieder da.
Was macht Benni aktuell? Keine Ahnung, ich habe, ist nicht so, dass ich großartig Kontakt mit, mit einem von beiden noch hätte.
Ähm, ich gehe jetzt off und in zwei, drei Stunden oder so bin ich wahrscheinlich wieder am Start.
Und dann gucken wir uns Nextcloud an.
Ja, bis denn, macht's gut.
See you.